this is Ben Shapiro last night on uh
Pier's Morgan uh and he talks about his
spat with Tate and and basically just
blows this whole thing apart how did you
engage with him what do you feel about
that well what I feel about that is that
he was tweeting that immediately like as
terrorists were still running around in
southern Israel that was on October 10th
and he was still Tweeting while the
bodies were fresh and warm in the
streets peace is you cannot make peace
with people who murdered your children
and burned their bodies you can't do
that the murder happens and you
immediately say okay well guys now true
now truce now I'll ceas fire that is not
no State worth its salt no government on
Earth would allow this kind of insanity
and no government on Earth would listen
to nonsense about how you immediately
have to seek peace with a group that
seeks your direct extermination by the
way and I'm not going to be lectured on
morality and toughness by by Andrew Tate
whose great idea of toughness and
morality is pimping women and then
bragging about it on air